marvel's one division is a big hit on
disney plus and
the highest rated mcu production ever
which honestly can only mean one of two
things
either we've all been starved for marvel
content or
disney's been spending way too much on
fight scenes apparently what people
really want to watch is the avengers
picking out baby furniture
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
now in technicolor
you know if you're like me you've been
glued to the tv every friday to check
out the new episodes of marvel studios
as wanda vision
partly for the intrigue partly for the
memes but mostly to watch the two most
overpowered avengers do something other
than hanging back during battle so
hawkeye doesn't feel
even more useless seriously let clint go
home to his wife and tractor already
arrow man is out of his depth but in all
seriousness one division is like my
perfect show
one that recreates the tropes of classic
television and then twists them to
create a meta commentary on the medium
while
also weaving together a compelling
mystery where no one has any idea what's
going on i think something's wrong here
if the number of requests i've gotten to
cover this series is any indication lots
of people are feeling just as confused
as vision about what's really going on
here and since those heartless monsters
at disney are making us wait a whole
week in between episodes gave us some
time to work a few things out
maybe correct the case of not only one
division's big mystery but also the
shocking twist for the near future of
the marvel cinematic universe itself
what if the secret villain of one
division
and the next phase of the mcu as a whole
is wanda maximoff herself
ho-ho-ho wanda stans don't smash that
dislike button all at once so you can
smash that subscribe button to help push
this channel over 10 million subscribers
let's look at the fact shall we if you
read the online theories the prevailing
thought is that the big bad wand
division is setting up is mephisto who
is
quite literally the marvel equivalent of
the devil he does
largely what the devil tends to do in
stories he makes deals with people and
then tries to trick him into selling
their soul
so why would the internet hive mind make
this huge leap that classic sitcoms
automatically lead to santa himself
so why would the internet hive mind make
this huge leap that classic sitcoms
automatically lead to satan himself well
lots of small things really first
there's wanda's neighbor
who's always wearing a brooch and is
dressed in a witch costume in the
trailer
her name is agnes very close to ag
tha agatha harkness a character from the
comics who also
always wears a broach and is a witch and
just so happens to be a servant of
mephisto
add to that the fact that she says this
the devil's in the details bev
that's not the only place he is which is
more than a little suspicious
during that episode's fake commercial
break take a look at the back of the
toaster
if you flip the image vertically it says
a number commonly associated with the
devil and even
outside of wandavision we see the devil
starting to appear in other corners of
the mcu
in the trailer for the disney plus
series loki we see in a church of some
kind with a stained glass window that
clearly depicts
the dark lord of all things now that one
is
super weird and considering how marvel's
release calendar is looking the only
places it really makes sense for the
devil to be introduced is either in loki
or
you guessed it wandavision so there you
have it mephisto
is the main villain of wandavision and
moving forward will be the big bad of
phase five but hey that's just a
theory
if you read the online theories the
prevailing thought is that the big bad
wand division is setting up
is mephisto except for one thing marvel
knows how much we pour over this stuff
to find out what's gonna happen
they do all kinds of witchcraft to
obscure the truth and make us buy into
false realities from thor's missing eye
and ragnarok to thanos's infinity stones
and in this case
i think the mephisto easter eggs are
just that fun references
to misdirect super fans because adding
mephisto into the story at this point
is too risky not from a narrative
standpoint or not wanting to get
supernatural with it nothing of the sort
i think it's too risky for one reason
china china as you might suspect is a
huge market for movies
it's the second largest in the world in
fact by a large margin but in order for
your movie to release in china it has to
follow some pretty harsh censorship
rules for instance did you know that
iron man 3 had four
extra minutes inserted into it in order
to get released in china including an
extra scene where it suddenly turns into
a chinese medical drama
that is not nearly as jarring as the
moments when the film promotes tony
stark drinking chinese milk products
which were put in there to ease the
population's concern over milk
tainted with mercury no joke anyway
china tends not to release any movies
that are critical of the country's past
or current political regime
and along with that is a ban on ghosts
or things of a supernatural nature
for instance this ban resulted in the
censorship of the controversial film
babe pig in the city because the censor
had a policy against talking animals
granted marvel has certainly had its
fair share of luck with the chinese
sensor board in the past
endgame got a pass despite back to the
future being censored for its use of
time travel
but disney has recently run into issues
with china after the release of mulan
and disney plus is still struggling to
release in the country so storylines
that heavily feature the lord of the he
double hockey sticks dimension would
probably be a risk that they're not
willing to take right now besides the
more
interesting narrative here and the one
that all the clues are pointing to is
that the real villain of wand division
and the thing that'll kick off the
entirety of phase five
is wanda herself as she rips holes into
the multiverse either
out of anger or grief don't believe me
it's easy to forget at this point but
she
started as a villain in avengers age of
ultron where she and her twin brother
pietro were super powered henchmen for
hydra and since then she has been
through
a lot as a child she was present when
her parents were killed by a stark
industry mortar shell
if that wasn't bad enough she was then
trapped for days next to a second
undetonated stark bomb we were trapped
for two days every effort
to save us every shift in the bricks i
think this will set it off
we wait for two days for tony stark to
kill us
by the end of the movie she loses her
brother and her entire country of
sokovia
and it doesn't get any better for her
when she becomes a good guy she's blamed
for the accident that leads to the
passing of the sokovia accords and
causes avengers civil war which then
forces her to live as an
outlaw she had to see her beloved vision
die twice
once by her very own hand in infinity
war
and then she gets dusted only to come
back and have
everyone she was friends with in the
team like black widow and captain
america either
gone or dead in the final scene of
endgame she's aligned with
falcon it makes no sense she is alone
at this point in the series i mean all
of that is enough to knock the fake
russian accent out of anybody
you said we would destroy the avengers
well there are people who are expecting
me too you know we both made promises
see i forgot to tell you my wife is from
europe what is it the joker always says
all it takes is one bad day
well wanda has had bad decades so wanda
is definitely in a fragile state when we
last see her in endgame but wanda's
inner struggle between good and evil
isn't just evident in the mcu
it's inspired directly from her origins
in the marvel comics
there she and her brother quicksilver
were founding members of the og x-men
villains the brotherhood
of evil mutants and you know they're the
bad guys because they put it in their
name
the brotherhood was a family business
their leader magneto
yeah that magneto was wanda and pietro's
dad the maximoff twins didn't turn to
the side of good until they joined the
avengers in avengers number 16
and while they've mostly been heroes
ever since there has been some back and
forth in comics like avengers 53 and
x-men 45. now
obviously the mcu doesn't follow the
comics to the letter so why does any of
this matter
well because they very often go back to
the comics for inspiration
and while bond vision is indeed an
original story it seems to be taking its
cues from three specific marvel
storylines the vision and the scarlet
witch limited
series avengers disassembled that you
can figure out how that one goes and
house of m
all of which tell very different but
connected stories with
one big thing in common they all had
dark plot twists involving reality not
being what it seems
and wanda being the cause of it at first
glance
vision in the scarlet witch seems to be
the most similar to monovision in that
it's a fun sort of marvel story mostly
about the characters trying to live
normal lives in the suburbs including
wanda using her scarlet witch powers to
conceive her twin sons
tommy and billy sound familiar time
yes tommy there's another baby coming
even though this quirky 80s miniseries
is a mostly happy story it gets an
unexpectedly dark conclusion in the
pages of west coast avengers a few years
later when it's revealed that billy and
tommy
didn't actually exist no really in a
twist worthy of a mid-tier m night
shyamalan movie it turns out billy and
tommy
are illusions that wanda willed into
existence from her own subconscious
without ever
realizing it i know right how would that
work you know how in the movies they
never really explain what wanda's powers
are and they don't really make a whole
lot of sense well in the comics they do
explain them and they still don't make
sense why was she up there all this time
the simple version is that she can alter
probability in the nature of reality
itself so
basically she's not so much throwing
cars at your face as she is creating a
new reality wherein cars are now on top
of your face anyway the whole
make-believe baby thing was arranged by
mephisto and a guy named master
pandemonium whose name sounds a lot like
the opening band for a mega death
concert and who it's worth noting
literally had babies for hands yeah i
know anyway as you can imagine finding
out your entire reality and your
children was a lie created in your own
subconscious
it's gonna be kinda traumatic so every
memory that was related to tommy and
billy gets erased from wanda's memory
never to be mentioned again
but then 20 years later in the massive
end of an era reboot event avengers
disassembled marvel decides hey
remember that time you thought you had
twins but you didn't because satan would
be as good of a reason as any for the
scarlet witch to lose her mind
so hard she nearly destroys the avengers
in disassembled the avengers are
systematically destroyed by a series of
disasters betrayals
personal failings and reappearances by
some of their worst enemies nearly all
of which turn out to be
illusions or psychic manipulations
caused by the scarlet witch's
reality changing powers the whole thing
forces them to get a new clubhouse let
wolverine join the crew and
ultimately reboot the issue numbering so
it was mostly an excuse to shake up the
lineup and redecorate but it was a huge
deal in terms of redefining wanda as one
of the most powerful characters in the
marvel comics universe after that came
house of m which gave her powers yet
another frightening dimension
literally when it's revealed that wanda
can do more than just change her own
reality she can create
an entirely new one in house of m she
traps the entire marvel universe in an
alternate version of itself where her
brother is alive again and
everyone who is still mad at her from
the last thing so you know like a lot of
people
would hopefully forget reality because
they suddenly had new lives based on
their greatest wishes coming true
spoiler alert doesn't work not a great
plan leading to her iconic line
no more mutants where she erases all
mutant powers from existence
more or less it's a bit of an
oversimplification but that's the broad
strokes so already i bet you could start
seeing a lot of parallels here a
storyline about wanda and vision
living a perfect suburban life and
having two kids under mysterious
circumstances getting some big
vision and scarlet witch vibes there her
rewinding the show to rewrite how events
proceed when she doesn't like the
direction things are going
no
it shows that she has control over this
world her getting mad and eating people
out of sitcom land when things just
become a bit too real
it tells us that she has created
intentionally or otherwise an
alternate reality inside of this bubble
a perfect world where she can exist
alongside her dead robot lover and her
make-believe children
is that why the other characters are so
afraid of her are they prisoners trapped
inside of wandavision's alternate
reality the same way that the entire
marvel universe was trapped in the house
of m
reality hey future matpat jumping in
here who knew episode four would reveal
quite so much kind of sucks when your
episodes take two weeks to produce means
that you're working with three weeks
worth of information when episode four
is
also there so you just kind of gotta
cross your fingers and hope it doesn't
blow too many things up
anyway uh this last point actually seems
to be confirmed in this latest episode
we see them go through
person by person showing that the cast
of the show are townsfolk that are
trapped in this reality
all except for one notable exception who
goes unnamed there was no mention of
agnes
suspicious i think so a key part of the
three storylines we just talked about
from the comics is that wanda doesn't
necessarily turn evil
in them it's just that when she loses
control of her subconscious
it sometimes goes to bad places and does
bad things so it's entirely possible
that while she is the one controlling
things in one division she's not
actually
controlling them herself she's not aware
that she's the one controlling them she
might be unconscious or sedated or even
in a coma i mean think about this in
psychoanalytic dream theory of the type
popularized by sigmund freud the
subconscious mind rearranges seemingly
unrelated images and ideas into
symbolically recognizable new forms
which we then recall as dreams in our
subconscious
like say a traumatic memory about a
ticking stark time bomb
becoming a creepy ticking stark toaster
commercial
top and bottom heating elements can
handle anything
[Music]
the all-new toastmate 2000 by stark
industries
hear that suspicious ticking of the
toaster listen again
top and bottom heating elements can
handle anything
and that ominous flashing light that my
friends is no toaster
that is the ticking time bomb of
childhood trauma we wait for two days
for tony stark
to kill us then there's the commercial
in episode three about soap which is a
reference to agent coulson's theories
about hydra using soap as a mind control
device would have figured it out a long
time ago if it wasn't for the mind
control soap
yeah wait what hydra loads it up with
chemicals
it seeps into our bloodstream and plants
false memories into our brains
they want us to believe this is a
magical place i make my own soap now
even the black and white palette could
be wanda's subconscious calling back to
vision's death in infinity war
yeah his whole body turned monochrome
which might just cause her subconscious
to associate the black and white
aesthetic of old tv
with the last memory of that person
being dreamed back to life
now that is meta hey future matpat again
this is another one of those things
that's nearly confirmed in episode four
after wanda is reminded of the reality
outside of her sitcom bubble she
temporarily sees vision in his real
dead form again he's in monochrome am i
the only one thinking that she may just
be puppeteering the dead body of her
boyfriend because if so
that would be awesome in short the
undeniable truth here is that vision is
dead and there's a high likelihood that
the children aren't real
or if they are they're gonna be taken
from her for the
when the laugh track dies and the retro
clothes go away at the end of the series
which you know they're going to
she's going to be left alone which means
this series is going to end with one
very unhappy very powerful witch running
loose in the mcu who now's unlocked the
ability to make reality
bend the knee is there a doctor in the
house perhaps a
master of the mystic arts after all case
you forgot elizabeth olsen
is scheduled to play scarlet witch again
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness in early 2022 but they never
said she was one of the good guys olson
is also starting to talk up rumors that
she might just pop up in the third
spider-man movie you know the one that's
also supposed to be dealing with
alternate universes coming together the
one that's also set to feature a
previously confirmed guest appearance by
doctor strange and the one that's set to
hit theaters only three months before
multiverse of madness multiverse of
madness man that is such a stupid name
it's
it's like really cheesy like awkwardly
cheesy
wait a minute multiverse of madness
m-o-m
[Laughter]
if you ask me it looks like marvel's
newest mom is likely to end wandavision
ripping open reality in an attempt to
reclaim her happiness and
maybe even her kids with the rest of
phase 5 needing to sort it all out and
by the end
disney gets to keep who they like they
get to lose who they don't and they get
an excuse to introduce the
x-men without breaking the established
continuity of
all the movies that came before no more
mutants more like bring on the mutants
all it takes is for mom to go a little
bit mad but
wait future matpat here to chime in one
final time
all of this would actually be a pretty
bad look for disney their first
female hero black widow is like the
first major character to get killed off
in these movies and then their second
one turns evil because
babies is not a good look for them and
rewatching these episodes with number
four now in consideration i think we're
actually gonna have ourselves a
scapegoat i do think everything that i
said in today's theory is still gonna
wind up being true but i think that
there's one
final layer to all of this that someone
is actually going to be revealed to be
using
wanda throughout this whole thing kind
of like mephisto in the comics and the
hexagons
are the things to prove it if you were
paying attention to the first three
episodes you saw
hexagons everywhere throughout the
series but episode four
really just explicitly called it out
outright making question number one
why hexagons and well sure the mind
stone was
technically a hexagon the real easter
egg that
solves this is right here episode 4
5 minutes and 40 seconds the new
director of sword has his diplomas on
the wall in a strange
hexagon pattern that matches wanda's
reality bubble
every other hexagon has been created
within wanda's reality but this one
is in the actual world with no other
reason of being put there except to act
as a clue to us
the viewer i mean why spend so much time
at sword headquarters why
introduce this new character my guess is
that wanda has been to this office and
that the hexagons might be her
subconscious reacting to a memory of
being in that director's room
another hint comes from the difference
between the comic sword organization
that we see hinted throughout various
symbols in the series and the mcu
sword you see both titles are backronyms
but while the comic sword is named
sentient world observation and response
department the sword in the mcu
is ominously named sentient weapon
observation and response division
this title indicates that rather than
dealing with intergalactic threats the
mcu sword is interested in sentient
weapons and how to deal with them
human weapons that have gone out of
control weapons
like wanda we even have this out of
place line shoved in there
it also says observation and response on
that door
not creation this line is meant to clue
us in that these people have made
weapons in the past and it looks like
the director might be in the process of
doing it again
because consider this if wanda's kids
are in fact real
if this whole simulation is somehow
orchestrated by sword
for the children and they're taken from
her we have ourselves
truly the first characters actually born
with superpowers in this universe
they would be the first ever mutants but
hey
that's just a theory a film
theory and hey there all you hep cats
yes
you watching this video have you
considered smacking that subscribe
button it's the swellest thing that'll
keep you smartest on the block or if you
want another theory about phase 5 of the
mcu
watch out how thor might be the one to
turn evil in the cosmic
universe until next time theorists